did you see empire last night with
justice Millette now the episode was
filmed before his alleged assault hoax
and according to the show's creator Lee
Daniels the scandal has hit this cast
hard these past couple of weeks have
been a friggin roller coaster in the
beginning Lee Daniels stood by Jesse
after the alleged attack but he vented
on how the hate crime scandal has
affected Empire me and my cast have
experienced pain and anger and sadness
and frustration and really don't know
how to deal with it you know this guy
stayed riding last night's episode was
shot before the alleged assault occurred
on January 29th everything has happened
which you were seeing prior to the
incident but you ain't the only ones
going through stuff taraji P Henson who
plays Jesse's mother on the show gave us
her tape of the feeling on the set it's
a great atmosphere yeah anything else
you could tell us about sort of how you
all are dealing with this I can't really
talk about that
jesse was indicted on 16 felony counts
by a grand jury in Chicago he pled not
guilty and has insisted on his innocence
since the beginning or his character
Jamal Lyon was written out of the final
two episodes of this season's Empire
Jesse's final episode this season is
April 24th the season finale is May 8th
but the promo for next week hints at a
major character death which Lyon will
end up
Six Feet Under I mean I think we all
know that Jesse's character is the
number one candidate to end up in that
coffin by the way back in the real world
Jesse's next court appearance is
scheduled for April 17
[Music]